so copernicium or cabinets IAM as the
discoverers would prefer to be
pronounced is the latest name to go up
on the periodic table and it's really
very exciting it's the first time for
many years that a new name has appeared
and not only has it appeared but quite
excitingly it's appeared with a bit of
controversy
what should the symbol be the first
suggestion was that it should be cool
this symbol should be C P capital C with
little P and that got really quite an
argument in organic chemists who use
organic groups in their compounds got
quite excited because C P is the symbol
that's used for the cyclopentadienyl
iron which binds to all sorts of
different metals and then it was
discovered or realized that many many
years ago CP was used as an alternative
symbol for element number 71 lutetium
which in some countries were called casa
opium and i've looked in lots and lots
of books that i've got at home and i
can't find one of them that uses this
name but the reason why it's important
is because now more and more old papers
old books are being digitized on the
internet if you start searching for the
symbol C P it will start throwing up old
papers and cause confusion so the
decision has been made by the
International Union of a pure and
applied chemistry that or the
recommendation is that the symbol should
be C n capital C little n and I think
this is a very sensible suggestion
because it is unlikely to can be
confused with cyanide which is capital C
capital N and it's also nice for our
Chinese colleagues because C n is the
domain name for Chinese websites and I
think most chemists will be very happy
with that the element itself
made first made quite a few years ago
and it's made like all these heavy
elements by taking the nuclei of two
atoms that are lighter and banging them
together and if you're aiming for
element 112 then you need to take two
nuclei the which have atomic numbers
which when you add them together come up
to 112 so in this case you take lead
which is atomic number 82 and so to get
from 82 to 112 you need to add 30 so you
accelerate zinc atoms which have masses
atomic number of 32 Ords these in of
high-speed accelerator and they feel
every so often and quite rarely these
two nuclei fuse together to give you an
element or an atom of element 112 when
you make the atom it exists for a short
time which might be a thousandth of a
second or a few thousandths of a second
might be as long as half a second or
even a second and then the nucleus of
the atom starts to decay now it doesn't
blow into part two just two protons and
neutrons in one row whoosh but instead
it starts going down by steps usually
the atomic number changes by two units
or one unit depending what sort of
particle is ejected from the nucleus so
in the case of 112 and I don't know the
details yet it will decay for example
the first step might be good to 112 over
to hot from 112 to 110 then the second
step might be just one unit to 109 and
then to down to 107 and so on until you
get to an element below the mass of
uranium 92 which is stable